[Music]
how are
you I know now we're in New York in New
York the last time we were in La when
you yeah yeah now you're on my turf I
know I like it I love it there's You'
been very busy here yes you you have a
new podcast right now right do you love
it I do I love it's called Hay spirit
and I love being able to connect people
you know all over the world and you know
over a zoom it's amazing on how Spirit
really validates that they're still with
us it's absolutely incredible yeah and
it's also like even scheduling too in
your life like it's kind of cool you can
schedule a podcast more around you which
is nice yeah um well Teresa says she
connects to those who have passed on
through something she calls spirit so
you say Spirit guides you but do you
ever feel that like physically yeah so
what happens is a lot of times when
Souls when they first start to
communicate with me they make me feel
like the bond that they shared with the
person but a lot of times they'll just
bring me through the departure they'll
make me feel what they felt as the soul
left the physical body that's it seems
rude yeah well not rude I'm like God it
was hard it it is very hard I always say
I make what I do look very easy it's the
hardest thing that I have to do is to
stand in front of someone and take them
on this emotional roller coaster of
feeling pain sorrow loss and grief and
then try to give them peace and a little
bit of levity and laughter yeah to know
that their loved ones are still with us
and that's one of the reasons why I do
what I do it's not people to believe in
what I do I don't care I want people to
believe in themselves to believe in an
afterlife to know that their loved ones
souls are still with them just in a
different way and just to embrace those
things that that that remind you of them
it's that's beautiful but you so
whenever you say you feel it like do you
you actually feel it physically like
feel affected yeah like I could feel
like I'll I already knew when I was
standing back there that there was a
real tragedy um of a departure because I
kept like tasting blood and I kept
feeling like a blow to my chest so like
in the room like in here when I was
standing back back there getting ready
to yeah back there
oh that I'm wow that's heavy yeah cuz
then you don't want to walk out there
and go hey well you know that's the
thing you know people came here today
they didn't come to maybe expect to see
me they came to see you right they
didn't know I was coming and that's what
I always say spirit gives us what
exactly what we need to kind of restore
our faith yeah um and to know that they
are okay and more importantly that their
soul is at peace it provides probably so
much closure for people in just such a
peaceful it way yeah and you can't
imagine how many people pass and what
people are left with for whatever reason
and some people come they they don't
want to live anymore they don't know how
there are times where people haven't
spoken to other family members because
someone died and someone will come to a
reading and it will restore their faith
it'll give them a purpose to live
they'll reunite families that haven't
spoken so it is so much more than just
communicating with with people that have
died absolutely oh so your new show you
it say combines readings and your
personal life right correct so this is
like full on do you mind being on camera
a lot like that like all the time it's
so crazy like I don't even realize that
they're there I don't either it's noral
I think that's not normal but I don't
either to do you mind the cameras here
I'm like what cameras I'm like it will
be somewhere and I didn't even see it
well I talked to dead people so there
was around and nobody else could see it
so to me a camera you're like you're
always here yeah but it's the most
natural thing for me and the thing that
I love about raising Spirits it's cuz I
am on the road so much and I'm away a
lot and so they're on they're you know
on the bus with me they're seeing what
it's like in a in a day of a life of me
and it's I think people probably see how
draining it must be and feel and that's
a that's an emotional roller coaster all
the time every time you're talking with
someone is it sure it sure is yeah but I
wouldn't trade what I do for anything in
the physical world I consider it an
honor and a privilege to be able to
share my gift and to give someone some
peace and comfort and the fact that
people trust me with the souls of their
departed loved ones means the absolute
world to me so it's an honor to do what
I do so you told us before um but remind
us what it's like for you when you start
connecting so what happens is I just
feel immediately drawn so I was drawn to
this area but more I was more drawn to
this area over here down here and up in
here um and I just keep feeling there's
just one soul that keeps bringing me
through a very traumatic departure so I
keep getting like a blow to the chest
and I keep tasting blood so that's my
symbol for with someone passed uh
tragically and I always say um you know
like like I said earlier like nobody
came here today thinking that they might
hear from their loved one that has died
I always deliver messages it is because
sometimes someone might be afraid or not
know what to expect when their loved one
does come through what they might say
but I can guarantee you it will always
be things of Faith and
Healing so I don't want anyone to be
afraid do you understand that the
tragedy up over here
ma'am a week ago
okay and very tragic is that correct
okay what so yeah actually because now
do you feel like a chill or like some
type of warmth moved through you warmth
yeah I asked the soul to move through
you to validate that the soul is present
because the reason why this is happening
because the you and the family are
afraid that the soul is not safe in
peace with God is that correct I mean I
think so right yeah yeah is that correct
yeah so just know that this is the
Soul's way of validating that they are
okay and more importantly that we could
not have prevented this departure wow do
you understand that yeah yeah because I
felt like I needed to take
responsibility for my
departure do you who understands the car
accident okay were you just talking to
them telling me that I go you're messing
up this reading over here I'm trying to
do this I'm so sorry so what I love
about that so sorry what validating for
you that they heard you do you
understand that what what plans changed
that day cuz what happened is they put
me in the car and they switched my seat
so that's my symbol for that plans
change that they they switch cars or
they switch
drivers what um well we were supposed to
go out together I stood home I acted
like I was asleep and she went with my
best friend it was both of them in the
car and usually when we went out
together I always took a ride with the
best friend but since I wasn't there my
sister did cuz she didn't like going in
the car with her and they they died they
both died and you have been carrying
this burden oh my God for years for
decades validating for you that they do
not want you to carry this burden a
feeling that if you were there or
somehow you could have been responsible
do you understand that or if you went
this never would have
happened so her I miss her and I love
her so much you just did ma'am she also
just told me that you connect with the
song on the radio that reminds you of
her it's not a current top 40 hit right
not playing it on purpose know that that
is her soul her energy that is with you
at the exact moment so know that she
wants to thank you for that and know
that everything that you see is truly
her and that she hasn't left you oh
thank you so much don't thank me thank
her she's the one that she's the one
that did it I love my she's the
best oh my god do we understand the
hitting of the head that was her okay
and do you think that she suffered I I
think she did it was a tragic car
accident cuz she hit me in the back of
the head and then what she did is she
then had this blow to the chest and she
made me feel like I I I didn't I
immediately left the physical body okay
so I was told that before Oh my God yes
she says I need you to believe that I
did not suffer to my death or if anyone
got to me sooner that I would still be
here thank God know that my soul
immediately left oh thank you God I'm
very sorry for the loss thank you so
much sister thank you so much I wish you
all the best I appreciate you God you do
this all the time this is so intense I I
could keep
going this is so intense
yeah yeah that was overwhelming to just
be in the room while all of that just
went down and you do that regularly and
I could I could still go I mean that
because it's almost like I felt like
when I first came out people like
thinking oh my God and then it's almost
like oh well I wonder if my loved one is
here I think that was me I should speak
up I should say something so I just say
to you all just Embrace and know that
the things that go on around you that
remind you of your loved one that has
died to know that that is them know that
there is an afterlife
and that they will greet us when we do
leave this physical world I can feel
like there are so many people that have
a million questions a million questions
right now and I understand and I read
with respect what I do is not for
everyone and I will never Force messages
on anyone I can see how that might scare
someone to where they' be quiet about it
and then talk about it later right and
that and that's okay it freaked me the
hell
out well give it up for Teresa Caputo
everybody Teresa Caputo raising
experience premieres on livetime
tomorrow night and catch her on tour
Teresa Caputo live The Experience go
online for
[Music]
[Applause]
tickets thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home